something that I'm incredibly excited to
finally talk to you about which is for
all mankind for anyone that's watching
right now for all mankind airs on Apple
TV plus you can stream the entire first
season right now it is one of my
favorite shows I loved it
and I know that you are currently in
post or working on season two but that's
a little bit ahead I want to jump
backwards for people that have never
seen it
how have you described the series to
people well it's it's an alternate
history series and it starts with the
premise of what would happen if the
Russians had beat us to the moon in 1969
and that one event just changes the
world you know because we lost the race
to the moon the United States got really
upset and just said what how could this
have happened and we're more than to
determine than ever to catch up to the
Russian so Nixon gets out of Vietnam
early we go all in on the space race the
Russians then put a woman on the moon
and the Americans go that's crazy where
our female astronauts so suddenly women
come into the program and social change
starts happening and basically the scope
the sweep of the series is saying if we
had really gone all in on the space
program and moved more aggressively to
the moon and to and to the beyond how
would things have changed technological
change happens faster in the United
States societal change happens faster in
the United States and the idea is that
this is a show that posits an alternate
history that's better than ours that
turned out well that it became a better
country a better world you know a better
future for Humanity and it became you
know it's a more positive idea of what
the future could be than what we had and
it's ultimately this is like the road
that leads you to a future like Star
Trek where it is an optimistic idea of
what's possible where technological
technology is our friend where we did
you know go out into the planets and
explore the solar system and created a
better world because of the
breakthroughs that the space program
inspired and some of the literal breaks
through this program itself discovered
I think apples done a tremendous job in
terms of giving you a budget to work
with to make this thing look spectacular
this is not the budget of Battlestar
Galactica
this is a whole different level can you
sort of talk about working with Apple in
terms of as a producer because you're
one of their original shows it's been
great you know it's interesting I was
there at the beginning you know the the
saw the platform created you know the
beginning of the network and the the
growing pains of that and the ideas of
what it was going to be and then Apple
as a company getting into content
creation for the first time really and
you know the marriage of Cupertino in
Hollywood and how that would go and it's
been fun it's been quite a ride it was
really thrilling to do some of the
things that we did and to it was great
to be part of the first slate of shows
there was you know there were things
like Tim Cook coming to the set and
sitting at Mission Control and talking
and being really excited because we got
the keyboards right and you know then
really he and I geeking out on the
monitors and just the fun of being in
Mission Control and it was it was a kick
you know it's it was really it was
really cool to do that and they've been
big fans in the show as you can imagine
Apple's obviously filled with people who
love technology and a lot of them grew
up loving the space program and you walk
through their offices and there's
pictures of space and astronauts and
spaceships all over the place and so
they were big supporters of what we were
doing they loved the fidelity with which
we you know we did the show and how
careful we were to really get the
physics ride and get the details right
about the period about the spacecraft
about what happens in space but what
being in the moon would really be like
and your attention to detail was
something they really valued I think
it's funny you brought up Tim Cook I've
always said that when it comes to Apple
like a series on Apple you need to find
out if Tim is watching just like you
need to find out if Jeff Bezos is
watching your show on Amazon you know
yeah because if they're watching you'd
like to think they're gonna say yeah
we're gonna keep green lighting that you
know you would know but to talk a little
bit about so you you go in and you did
how did this land at Apple and I'm
curious when you were talking to Apple
about it were you laying out this idea
of how much do they want to know this is
a five season show or you have ideas
that can go for a long time you know
what I mean yeah I mean they didn't I
just kind of pitched the show to them I
mean it happened because Zach Van Amburg
who used to be head of one of the heads
of television at Sony Pictures he and I
had worked together for several years he
left and then took over the reins with
his partner Jamie Erlich to be the head
of Apple TV plus and once he made that
transition Zach called me up and said
hey come on over and let's talk and so I
came over to his office and we were
sitting and talking about shows and he
said to me you remember that idea we had
a few years ago about a show at NASA in
the 70s and it I went oh my god that's
right because he and I had had a casual
conversation about NASA in the 70s he
grew up Skylab was like something he
remembers as a kid so it kind of been
printed on his brain and there was a
brief moment when we talked about doing
a TV show Senate NASA during that time
here and nothing ever came of it
so then when I was at his Apple office
he and he said remember that show I said
yeah he said let's what if we did that
what if we did like a madman in space
said in the 70s wow that's really kind
of cool let me go think about it so I
went off and thought about it and I
thought immediately well you could
absolutely do that show you could do a
straight-up character piece ala madman
that's like about the office politics
and about the people who work at NASA
time period but to me as a space
aficionado it's like a sad story because
it's basically a time of budget cutbacks
it's a time when the lofty ambitions of
NASA keep getting smaller and smaller
and smaller we're not going to Mars
we're not doing moon bases we're not
doing big space stations we're just
gonna do the shuttle and a couple of
little things here and there and it's
kind of depressing and I said what if we
did the alternate history version and we
did the space program that I thought we
were gonna get when I was a kid well you
know the the space program that I was
promised you know when I was watching
Apollo the glories of Apollo and you
were thinking about all these amazing
things were gonna happen that there was
a road between here and Star Trek I was
gonna get to see a lot of that happen
over the course of my lifetime and that
didn't come to pass so it felt like
there was an opportunity to do a series
that was about that very idea and watch
the space program become much bigger and
watch how it you know changes the world
and he totally bought into he was like
that's really cool and then it just
became about you know well what would
change and why would it change and then
it was all about you know working out
the story
well what I'm curious about is obviously
you are you are you start at a certain
point and then you start veering and I'm
just curious as you guys have been
developing the show how much are you
sort of figuring out all those things
that have now the new tree branch is
growing that way and how all the things
start going in a new direction
yeah I mean one of the very first things
I did is we were getting ready to put
the writer I was hiring the writers and
we were gonna have our first real
sessions and I took some time and I sat
down and I wrote up an original
alternate timeline just going from 1969
well into the future and just like what
would be the changes I wanted to play
and just wrote out a long timeline of
all those alternate events some things
would still take place some things would
happen differently or maybe happen later
but I wanted it to to track coherently
with the history that we know I mean I'm
a history buff and a political buff so I
tried to weave those events into the end
of the timeline as best they could then
as we started working out the series in
the writers room we were constantly
talking about changes to history and
what would change and what would not
change what are the familiar names that
would still be around and what were the
names that would just disappear that
wouldn't even be mentioned anymore you
know when the first things that came up
was okay we're gonna get out via he's
we're getting out of Vietnam early Nixon
goes all in on the space program well
you got to get out of Vietnam because
it's sucking resources and political
capital and lives and it's like that has
to go away which he wanted to get out of
anyway so he could pivot to the to the
competition with the Soviet Union in
space then you start saying well what
happens to Nixon and we said I think
Nixon well the first domino to back up
is the Russians land on the moon Ted
Kennedy doesn't go to Chappaquiddick as
a result because in real history
Chappaquiddick happened just like a week
before the Apollo 11 moon landing so in
our in our timeline because the Russians
get there first Kennedy goes back to
Washington to attend congressional
hearings to find out how we lost the
moon so he doesn't go to Chappaquiddick
now he's a viable presidential candidate
in 1972 and in 72
he's like the representative the
brother of the slain leader who put us
on the space race to begin with and
fights against Nixon in 72 and he wins
then we started thinking well if if
Nixon loses in 72 what happens to
Watergate and we realized well there's
probably the Watergate break-in has
happened but the big scandal really
doesn't break until after 72 so it never
becomes this big thing they never find
the tape recording system so Ted
Kennedy's probably still using the tapes
in his office and we're still recording
conversations let's keep using that
device and Watergate never becomes a
giant political thing so and it's just
one piles on top of the other piles on
top of the other and becomes really
fascinating and fun one of the big
losses of that whole storyline that Matt
Walker pointed out was well then no
one's ever gonna make the movie all the
president's men and what a tragedy what
a tragedy that is and I did feel like oh
that kind of sucks there's no all the
president's men in our in our timeline
for people that are fans like me can you
sort of talk about where you're at in
the development of season two we yeah
we've shot season two almost all the
episodes when the kovat Christ has
happened we we saw it two episodes to
complete so we have eight episodes
pretty much in the can we've been
working on post-production online ever
since we're starting to talk about
season three and we we haven't opened
the writers room yep or hopeful that we
will season two takes us you know if you
saw the very the tag the post-credits
sequence at the end of season one you
know the season two takes us into 1983
ninth and it's in the midst of the Cold
War's gotten even more colder you know
Reagan is president and the
confrontation with the Soviet Union is
front and center so the second season is
really a cold war story about the US and
the USSR thank you so much for giving me
your time and for people that are
watching right now I really can't
recommend for all mankind enough it is
so well done very grounded and just a
really really great show
absolutely well thank you for having me
on and take care and everybody be safe
thank you so much have a great day you
too